let me slip into something more
Gryffindor and I'll be ready to go
[Music]
teleporters you forget
so glad you could join us
[Music]
so many feelings first and foremost do
you happen to know all the lines from
Parent Trap stop wasting my time
you've managed to evade I know Rob for
long enough
never send in a Walther duplicate to do
when I own a duplicates job sorry I
wasn't listening um that outfit amazing
and I imagine with robes like those
you'd like to go to the magical place
that is Hogwarts yes yes I would thank
you really the place where children are
trapped on staircases for weeks
professors aren't properly vetted to
ensure student safety and the
all-you-can-eat buffets are just candy
you thought you are doing a top five
best episode you thought the Harry
Potter movies were heartwarming think
again they're not as perfect as you
remember well yeah I mean okay
are we talking awkward humor at
plotholes poorly a CGI problematic these
are the top five worst Harry Potter
movie moments number five
maxy
[Music]
look I'm really gonna try not to
continuously compare the movies to the
books but this was one detail I couldn't
move past bow batons and durmstrang are
both co-ed schools however in the film's
bow batons is portrayed as an all-girl
school and durmstrang and all-boys
school which makes their entrance into
Hogwarts a little cliched because girls
sigh and fart butterflies when they walk
in boys bang sticks in the ground and
breathe fire duh honestly these unique
introductions would not have been
weakened by including another gender
durmstrang was literally founded by a
woman a Narita Vulcan OVA and Nicholas
Flamel attended Bo Bhutan's I will say
the uniform designs from both visiting
schools were absolute perfection
they really showcase the different
climates and cultures but I really think
some boys were cheated out of some sweet
Sookie blue robes and bow batons female
champion makes it feel like the only
reason they were invited to the
Triwizard Tournament was for a diversity
hire
rather than floor earning her spot to
defend her school's legacy it's like
seeing female achievement is okay but
only when a male isn't an option and not
because they were the best overall oh
well I guess in the movie verse only
French witches and Scandinavian wizards
are allowed in education number four
shoelace
this seam is so incredibly awkward it
makes my skin crawl but it's part of a
larger problem Ginny is just less
likable in the movies sure the films try
and stay focused on the main trio and
their struggles to stay well rounded
while fighting evil but I would argue
Ginny's story art from being controlled
by Baltimore and Chamber of Secrets to
marrying the chosen one at the end of it
all certainly earns her a spot of
interesting enough character that
deserves some extra screen time to round
her out no just keep her as a two
dimensional love interest okay Bonnie
right looks spot-on but the script makes
her so dull and underdeveloped Daniel
Radcliffe's lack of chemistry with her
certainly didn't do Ginny any favors
which made all the little stolen glances
feel so incredibly forced I don't even
want them to end up together but back to
the shoelaces this scene is the perfect
storm of whose job was it to recognize
this shouldn't be in the movie the
writing is clumsy why is she tying his
shoes but then great actors have made
shoddy dialogue work except the acting
here is just bad discover that moment
maybe try moving your eye line to the
floor so you can actually see his shoes
this might have been fixed by the
director realizing the bit wasn't
working and to move on or try something
new this was the best take was there
only one where's my editor the last line
of defense to work their magic and cut
around this or better yet delete this
clip from existence we're supposed to
accept these fleeting moments as a brief
escape from the mayhem caused by
Voldemort but seems like this make me
wonder if Bellatrix Lestrange is free to
kill someone else right now
preferably me number three
no moaning myrtle that that's a child
please stop
during the Triwizard Tournament as a
payback for an earlier kindness Harry is
given a hint by Cedric Diggory that he
should take the golden egg to the prefix
bathroom to decode the clue for the next
round within once he's nice and naked
Myrtle reveals herself and then doesn't
stop Harry makes it clear with his body
language that he's uncomfortable with
the ghosts advances and continually
readjust the bubbles for coverage from
myrtles peeking
Myrtle then suggests he put the egg
under water like Cedric which I guess
gives her a free pass to join him with a
suggestive grin the scene finishes with
her persistent disregard for Harry's
physical cues as she scoots closer to
him and then tries to peer below the
bubbles and after pretending to take a
bite out of him finally cozies up on his
shoulder hold on she admits to seeing
Cedric in the tub so weird to gather she
often peeps on bathing students then
sure the character Myrtle died as a
student at Hogwarts but since she's
played by a grown woman the creep factor
is not lessened is the ghost peeper
enough to deter anyone from the luxury
bathroom though let's see yelp review
sweet bath exclusive entry great
amenities amazing cleanliness ahh
but the little girl ghost that stared at
me full-on the whole time was
off-putting
4 out of 5 stars honestly better than
the things that pop up in the other
bathrooms at Hogwarts number 2
that's one of the oldest shootings to do
it for you absolutely sure yes this is
so out of character for Dumbledore let's
agree that an actor has the right to try
something unique with a character and
gasp it doesn't have to match the book
however lunging and yelling at Harry not
only wouldn't get the desired response
in that moment it isn't something that
aligns with Dumbledore's temperament
towards a student he has to ask as a
formality there are other professors and
visiting Headmaster's that need to know
how this was capable and who to blame
but Dumbledore didn't think Harry was
responsible if Dumbledore did believe
Harry was capable of crossing the Aged
line he created himself then why would
he charge at a potentially all-powerful
wizard
if Dumbledore suspected someone else
submitted Harry as a candidate
then why launched himself to berate a
scared underage student if he was second
guessing the goblets rules for his own
abilities
why take his aggression out on a
vulnerable orphan that's a bit harsh
this was more than just an actor trying
something new for a take to shake things
up there are different angles of this
interaction to keep continuity of and
minor physical violence which suggests a
combat or intimacy director would have
been consulted it's not all on Michael
Gambon's shoulders multiple people
signed off on this character portraying
immediate concern as losing control and
it's just completely out of line with
how calmly and sometimes even humorously
he reacts to other moments and the
amount of blind faith Dumbledore
continuously puts in Harry not my
Dumbledore and the number one worst
Harry Potter movie moment is
[Music]
this was weird gross and completely
unnecessary
Ron attempts to destroy the locket
Horcrux and as a defense mechanism it
uses Ron's greatest fears against him
starting with spiders which have been
pretty effective so far in the series
but maybe Ron was starting to see
results from the unsolicited exposure
therapy then the Horcrux tries to
convince him he's an unfit son his
mother wishing for a daughter and
preferring Harry Potter as a child over
himself then the locket goes for the
jugular showing the love of his life
Hermione
saying she too prefers Potter and it was
ridiculous for him to have thought he
stood a chance and then the kiss let's
take a moment to look at their creepily
smooth iridescent skin
honestly Horcrux at this point you got
me I will never complain about my pores
again but okay did we really need the
implied nudity why I'm watching this
with my parents the same response from
Ron could have been achieved with way
less if anything the Horcrux made Ron
mad enough to destroy it so not so smart
now are you locking even the actors had
difficulty with this scene daniel
radcliffe was taken by surprise at the
intensity Emma Watson found it
incredibly awkward and Rupert Grint had
to be kicked off set because he couldn't
take it seriously this moment didn't
serve the characters well and was
unnecessary to suggest a love triangle
because just as a reminder platonic
relationships with female characters are
okay and the students all have really
muggle haircuts I mean we couldn't get
like a magical barrette or something or
like a glitter flat top which reminds me
when were these movies set anyway yes
that's right the things you love are
actually terrible there's no need to
count down anymore wait wait a minute
where did the other two go
[Music]
these are the top five worst Harry
Potter movie moments looking for us that
may work on those in the Dino dimension
but you'll need something a lot more
personal to take care of me can freeing
go nice work
I mean yeah how didn't you know that
would work
oh I didn't but she said it would take
something personal and I had to try
something it looks like we got more
duplicates to worry about all we can do
is stick together and keep counting down
[Music]
[Applause]
you